[Music]
hudson
we finished analyzing that mainframe
that mason woods brought from yamato
and perseus was looking for the names of
sleeper agents dragovich used in 68.
give us those names
we'll get adler's team to track him down
perseus erase them
[ __ ] me there's only one place you're
gonna find that information now
the lubyanka building what kgb
headquarters
why didn't perseus get them there
himself i don't know
maybe he's operating without
authorization i'll let edler know
but we're gonna do this the right way
we're not gonna do it at all
just got word bilikov is back in moscow
you guys know the plan
bell you with me lazar be ready for
x-fil
are you taking him into the kgb with you
are you crazy
wait for mason or woods to return i
don't need mason or woods i need bell
he's got the skill we need
are you enjoying this you're risking the
entire operation unnecessarily
it's not unnecessary it's calculated
just understand that if you botch this
we can't get those names it's over
i know you can do this hudson doesn't
trust anyone he can't control
that new enlarger came in i set it up in
the darkroom
so
the lubianca building kgb headquarters
in moscow
the sleeper agent records are stored in
the archives 100 feet below ground in a
nuclear defense command bunker
your only way in or out is through this
high security elevator
we'll need proper credentials that's
where our asset bellicoff comes into
play
melikov has been our source inside the
kgb for nearly a decade
he'll get us in he came through for us
in yamato he'll do it again
this [ __ ] is crazy even by his standards
you sure he's on board
an immediate nuclear threat warrants
every risk at this point
i'm sure he wouldn't disagree sims get
bella cough on the line
[Applause]
singapore
we're almost to the tunnels do you get
access to the bunker
that's what i like to hear
not yet i know you had this under
control
and one more thing one of our east
berlin informants recently switched
sides and fled from moscow
we have reason to believe in the
lubianca building today
he knows too much about our berlin
network i'm thinking in early retirement
good man now i know why hudson thinks so
highly of you
we'll meet you at the basement entrance
once you have the bunker key
you've been summoned to the conference
room upstairs secretary gorbachev is
here from the central community
you mean the one where he runs away with
the butler
detectives
british from what i understand that's
probably not in this year's
[Music]
have you ever been to poland
[Music]
hmm
have a seat general secretary brezhnev
has
taken an interest in the new security
development
there is a mole within the kgb the
committee wants someone from the first
chief directorate to oversee colonel
kravchenko's investigation
if you've not met him already this is
imran zakayev
thank you secretary gorbachev and thank
you all for welcoming me with open arms
i can think of no greater tragedy than a
home violated
from the inside the trust and love
within a family
is sacred apparently not everyone shares
your beautiful sentiments
comrade belikov as head of security i
understand you've practically exhausted
yourself
trying to unearth this mole how is that
gone
[Music]
yes and once we are finished with this
mole
he will be as blind and pureed as his
namesake
[Music]
until the mole is found i want security
increased around the bunker
zacchaeus do you have any
recommendations we should restrict
bunker access i also want to
cultivate closer relationships with all
of you
i want to know your hopes your fears
your ambitions
be thorough but we don't want any
significant disruptions
and you melikov who do you think should
retain bunker access during the
investigation
it pains me to say it but in a troubled
time like this
even generals need restrictions
secretary gorbachev only general charkov
should retain his bunker keeper now
very well see to it worry yourself no
longer sir
i've already ordered the bunker keys
collected
we are in grave danger from the
capitalists
our collective our very way of life
is at risk the traitor will be caught
and he will pay a high price for his
betrayal
belikov you are dismissed
[Music]
i'm being watched i need a bunker key
first i'll have to kill the cameras
have you ever been to poland
[Music]
sir
[Music]
um
this area is restricted if i'm spotted
here
now i need to hide the bunny
how about one of those lookers
[Music]
i have to get a bunker key for adler
you'll need it to access the vault
unfortunately cherkov now has the only
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's
well it was a pleasure
have you dug up my mood
no matter we've discovered additional
unauthorized communications
within hours we will know the exact
computer they came from
comrade i will be exposed soon
in the server room i could point
evidence towards czerkov
it's far too hot in here don't you think
[Music]
are you is
[Music]
good morning
the armory guard has a weakness for
cubans
okay perhaps a bribe could get me inside
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
comrade i will be exposed soon
in the server room i could point
evidence towards charcoal
it's far too hot in here don't you think
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so
the armory guard has a weakness for
cubans
okay perhaps a bride would get me inside
[Music]
come right back i will be exposed soon
in the server room i could point
evidence towards czerkov
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh
so
[Music]
so
cherkov that's absurd
where is your evidence
i have no idea how this got past me
jerkoff will be passing through here
soon when he does we will apprehend him
how long have you been spitting on
mother russia excuse me
do you know who you're speaking to i do
now
your medals will no longer protect you
please empty your pockets on the counter
have you lost your mind
now step over there and lift your eyes
off i'll take his back [ __ ] do it
is this your way of setting up my fall
kashenko
i'm looking forward to hearing the
response of the central committee
me too now go in that room without
saying another
how can i help you sir
luring two soldiers into the tunnel
should do the trick
here send a security detail to meet me
in the fairness room immediately
wasn't sure you'd come through i don't
have much choice do i
[Music]
this key card gives you elevator access
to the bunker
what about the uniforms
sounds like they're here now okay
i will lead them through and destroy
them you two do the rest
now take cover
this key card gives you elevated access
to the bundle
what about uniforms
sounds like they're here now okay
i will lead them through and distract
them you two do the rest
now take cover keep it clean
uniforms are no good to us bloody
foreign
[Music]
this key card gives you elevated access
to the bunker
what about uniforms
sounds like they're here now okay
i will lead them through and distract
them you two do the rest
now take cover keep it clean
uniforms are no good to us bloody
my
okay i have to leave but you should have
everything you need now if stopped
you are reporting the commander sober
get changed
[Music]
here our weapons and key card are in the
bag
[Music]
come on this way
once we're in the bunker on our own
[Music]
so
so
foreign
[Music]
no metal detectors for us we're going
around
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
take us down
be
elevator conversation always gets
awkward
gear up
they won't be happy to see us down here
wait for my words
foreign
play
keep moving towards the bottom
ugh
moving
[Music]
uh
things go south we need to secure our
expo plant a gas canister
good let's get to the ball
we're almost to the ball
oh
you grab the end zone watch
don't have much time before they get
through
there's the list bell copy it to a disk
running out of time pal we're cutting
through
[Music]
you're almost through the door
get ready here they come
[Music]
so
got the desk go
you're almost through the door
get ready
oh
be climbing out
got the disc let's go
follow me
way
oh
[Music]
we need to find a way out
this might be a way out
this is your final warning
well detonate the gas
when we move
what's the situation up top they add on
full of lift
nothing's pumping down we'll have to
fight our way out
we're gonna need some heavier gear i
know just a place
happening
let's move
look
get moving
let's get up top
[Music]
lazar meet us in the southwest courtyard
for five minutes
bellicott position plenty of room in the
backseat
once we get off the elevator just keep
moving towards the courtyard
get the charge ready though
let's go
up
keyboard
go go
so
foreign
got the list and we're heading back be
ready to move
[Music]
it's about time i've been waiting for
your call they caused a hell of a mess
in moscow
was it worth it adler managed to get the
list of sleeper agent names
despite himself he's got balls i'll give
him that
bell did well seemingly but i think that
team is getting too comfortable
they're acting like they know who
they're dealing with perhaps
turns out one of those sleeper agents is
tied to operation greenlike
theodore hastings he's a nuclear
engineer based out of stone lake city
and you believe hastings is the one
he'll activate
exactly total surveillance is already
underway
it's only a matter of time before he
leads us straight to perseus
you